uh hello everyone welcome to the second
lecture
in this workshop on games in equilibria
and it's my great pleasure to introduce
kusha
tasami sakusha is at university of
edinburgh and he
works in algorithmic game theory but
also
in temporal logix formal methods and
he's going to tell us
about some really interesting and very
recent work
on the complexity of computing task
fixed points on of monotone functions
uh so yeah please go ahead
okay so uh thank you very much uh for
inviting me to this
workshop it's a pleasure to speak here i
hope
um you're all coping well with our
very strange virtual existence and uh
okay so let's get started so this uh
i'll be talking about
basically a piece of joint work with
christos papier mitchu aveyad rubenstein
and mihaly cianakakis
that appeared last year at itcs
and the title of that paper was um
tarsky's theorem super modular games
and the complexity of equilibria in case
you want to look it up it's a different
title than
what i've used but it's basically the
same the subject
okay so let me try to oh
again i when i try to advance my slides
it's not doing it
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
apologies
um okay it's acting rather slow but
can you see the hand that i'm using to
point to the screen okay good okay so um
so let's just refresh our memory about
tarsky's fixed point theorem it tells us
that
a non-empty partially ordered set
is a complete lattice if
every non-empty subset of the set
l has both at least upper bound
and uh you know so in other words a
supremum or a join
and a greatest lower bound or in femum
or meat
okay so and and inside l of course so
and and a function from the lattice l to
itself
is called monotone if for any elements x
and y
if x is less than or equal to y then f
of x should be less than or equal to f
of y
let fix of f denote the set of fixed
points of this function
those elements of l that you know where
the function
f maps x to itself that's the set of
fixed points
and tarsky's classic fixed point theorem
tells us that
every monotone function from a complete
lattice to itself
has a non-empty set of fixed points
which themselves
form a complete lattice under that same
partial order
so in particular f has a least fixed
point
and the greatest fixed point etc okay
so the central question we're going to
be
addressing in this talk is how hard is
it
to compute a fixed point
by which i mean any fixed point of a
given monotone
function when and let's
just the things that we will talk about
will apply ultimately to also computing
things for
you know lattices that may not be finite
but let's focus for now on
finite lattices so that the
computational questions are
clear so where
so let's say where the lattice is finite
and to be even
more concrete more specifically
how hard is it when when this lattice is
the d
dimensional euclidean grid lattice by
which i mean
it is just you know
you know you know vectors in d
dimensions where each coordinate
is uh an integer between one through
capital n okay and where the ordering of
the lattice
is just the standard coordinate wise
ordering so
um you know coordinate by coordinate
comparison
okay so that's the partial order um
so yeah and this is just restating that
if x is less than or equal to y
if x i is less than or equal to y i for
every coordinate i
okay so as we will see
this question has important applications
including for equilibrium computation
problems in particular for super modular
games which
are very widely studied class of games
in economics
and also for uh solving or
computing the value of stochastic games
in particular like condoms simple
stochastic games and
shapley's original stochastic games
we will see also that this problem has
actually a rather intriguing
computational complexity status okay
so let's start off really easy
um this is just the kind of the most
easy algorithm you can think of
an indeed sort of cleaning and tarsky
already
pointed this very basic thing out is
if you want to find a fixed point of
such a monotone function
you can start at the bottom element of
the lattice that let's say in this case
that would be the all one
vector and you can just compute
the sequence starting from the all
vector of
you know applying f to that vector then
applying f to the resulting vector and
so on
um by monotonicity it follows very
easily
that for all i uh f i f applied i
times to the all one vector is less than
or equal to f applied i
plus one times to the all one vector
um no what and so what this means is
unless we reach some fixed point at some
at the i-th iteration you know or i plus
first iteration
where these are equal to each other
and before that it must be the case that
the sum of the
coordinates must increase by at least
one in each iteration since it's kind of
monotonic
so therefore we will reach a fixed point
in at most d times n iterations because
after all the value in each coordinate
is between one through n and there are
d coordinates so we will reach a fixed
point in d times n iterations
the fixed point that we compute in this
fashion is actually the least fixed
point
we can also similarly compute the
greatest fixed point by instead starting
at the top vector of the lattice at the
all n
vector okay so here's a very simple
question
suppose we don't actually care which
fixed point we want to compute so we
just want to compute
some fixed point can we do better than d
times n iterations and it turns out
indeed we can
and there's in fact um an algorithm
that was first uh published well not
published but
in a um a tech report from 2012 by dan
keaney which
basically computes a a fixed point of
such a monotone function in
log n to the d power iterations
by using a combination of binary search
and recursion
and i'll explain that algorithm now just
because i think
it's useful to see so
just some notation in order to you know
before i get to describe the algorithm
so
for two vectors a and b in this
finite lattice where a is less than or
equal to b
we'll let l a b denote basically the sub
lattice
between those two points a and b right
so these are all points
x who which are you know
between the points a and b okay
so in particular for example
our the the entire lattice will be
l from between all one vector and the
all n
vector as we had discussed uh before so
now in the one-dimensional case of this
um you know this
task of finding a fixed point for such a
monotone function
suppose we are simply given a monotone
function
you know from you know just the interval
of integers between a and b to the
interval of integers between a and b
okay and recursively a and b
are let's say between one and n okay
now we can compute a fixed point of such
a function
by binary search in the most obvious way
you can think of
we let the midpoint be you know the
halfway point between a
and b if we evaluate f at that midpoint
if the midpoint is a fixed point we are
done
if the if the function maps the midpoint
to something greater than the midpoint
then it must be the case that there the
the function is going to be monotone on
the segment between the midpoint
to the to the top element b and it's
going to map
that to itself right
and therefore it has a fixed point in
that region
and and likewise if the the function
decreases you know the value at the
midpoint
then the lower half will be mapped to
itself
right and the function you know
there is a fixed there's a fixed point
in that region and
you know so by repeating this we can
find the fixed point of you know the
one-dimensional
you know monotone function in log n
iterations just by basic binary search
okay so log n function evaluations
so how do we do recursion with more than
one dimension
so uh when the number of dimensions is
more than one
what we let me just introduce some
notation
so for
some some fixed integer
in in between one and n we're going to
use this
notation f you know bracket
c to denote a function now which is
in a sense a a slice
of the original function and what do i
mean by that it
it's a it's a d minus one dimensional
slice in the sense that it maps
uh you know the d minus one dimensional
lattice to itself
and it does so as follows the definition
is that basically in the i-coordinate i
going from 1 to d
the function is just what the original
function would evaluate to
if you just plug in c into the last
coordinate so in a sense
it's the slice of that function where
we've plugged in c into the last
coordinate and of course we're
ignoring what the original function
produced in its last coordinate
because you know we want this to be a
mapping from
the d minus one dimensional space to
itself okay
so note that this function is also a
monotone function
okay so this restriction is also a
monotone function this slice
now let us let c be kind of like
the halfway point between one and one
and n
okay if we recursively compute
a fixed point for this restricted
function that maps the
d minus one dimensional space to itself
then again
either when we then look back
at the d coordinate that last coordinate
that we were ignoring
in our recursion if we look back either
in that last coordinate
when we plug in that fixed point from
the lower dimensional space together
with c
in that last coordinate if we get back c
then we know that this is actually a
fixed point for the original function
and we're done
if on the other hand in that last
coordinate the function value is
increased
then what it means is that you know the
whole function the function
f maps in a sense
the points above this
vector x star c to the points above that
vector x
star c and that constitutes a sub
lattice
okay uh okay and that is
which is monotone and we have in effect
because we chose c
as the halfway point in that last
coordinate
we have half the range of values that we
have to consider in that last coordinate
in our search
for a fixed point and likewise if in
that last coordinate the value was being
moved down
then we could similarly uh you know
have the the search space you know by
because it will have been the k it will
be the case that
uh the function the original function
will map
you know kind of all the points below
this point to themselves
and again we have have the range of
values that we have to consider in the
last coordinate so
basically applying this recursively by
induction yields an algorithm
that requires well you know inductively
if it required
log to the d minus one and iterations in
the you know kind of
lower dimensional space then we have to
do binary search in that last coordinate
when that adds another factor of log n
so we get log to the dn
function evaluations in total to find
the fixed point for the function
so if there's any questions at the
moment i'm happy to answer but
i'll just assume that otherwise that
you're okay with that so yeah i have a
question
so again finds an arbitrary fixed point
right and the
absolutely yeah we have no control over
you know so which fixed point it is so
um you know it's not necessarily the
least or greatest or anything like that
okay so uh note that
for if d is kind of little o of log n
over log log n
then this algorithm beats
is better than the d times n algorithm
on the other hand
when d is omega of log n over log log n
the original you know sort of cleaning
iteration is actually better than this
uh log log into the d algorithm so these
are actually
sort of incompatible and it depends on
the relationship between the dimensions
and n okay okay
so can we do better than this okay
well let's just now step back a bit
and try to set this uh you know task
up as an explicit computational problem
okay so and which we will call the
tarsky problem
and what we're going to be defining is a
total search problem and so let me
explain what this problem is so
what we call the tarsky problem is that
we're given the function
uh that you know uh you know that maps
you know kind of d dimensional vectors
with integers between one and n to the
dimensional vectors
where capital n now is two to the little
n
for some uh uh non-negative n for some
positive n
where this is given to us this function
is given to us
by a boolean circuit with d times n
input gates and d times n output gates
you can really think of this as just
kind of a surrogate for a polynomial
time algorithm to compute this function
okay so the input is being given to us
succinctly as a boolean circuit
as giving us a way to compute uh you
know
this function you know efficiently as it
were okay
so as an output
we want either
to get a fixed point of the original
function
of that function but notice that we have
not
necessarily asserted we're not making a
promise that the
input function is a monotone so
in order to sort of avoid that promise
an alternative answer which we would be
also happy with is a witness pair of
vectors that witness non-monotonicity by
which i mean a pair of vectors x and y
such that x is less than or equal to y
and f of x is
not less than or equal to y coordinate
wise okay
so note of course that tarsky is a total
search problem if f is monotone
it will contain a fixed point okay and
otherwise it will contain such a witness
pair
of vectors that exhibit non-monotonicity
now
if f is non-monotone of course it may
contain both
a witness for non-monotonicity
non-monotonicity and
fixed points and it's important that
either output will do in that case
it's not that we're insisting on getting
witnesses for non-monotonicity because
in fact deciding whether such a given
function given by a boolean circuit is
non-monotone
is itself co-np-complete but this is
kind of a standard you know trick that
you do with
search problems is if you embed this
into the question itself
then it's you know we don't know so if
you get back
a fixed point you don't necessarily know
that the input function was
monotone or not because it could have
been non-monotone and yet you
still found the fixed point okay so but
anyway so this is the the general
definition of the tarsky problem
and it's done in this way so as to avoid
a promise
that the input function is monotone okay
any questions about that
okay so what is the complexity of this
total search problem
okay that's a natural question so
let me first before we delve into the
complexity of
of the starsky problem um
discuss actually a more difficult task
so
what if instead of the tarsky problem
our task was to compute
a specific fixed point let's say the
least fixed point
rather than just any fixed point well
that's np-hard so
you know if if you give me a monotone
function by boolean circuit
it even in just one dimension
it's already np hard to compute
the least fixed point of that function
and likewise it's np hard to compute the
greatest fixed point
and also in terms of the kind of black
box oracle model in terms of the number
of query evaluations of the function you
need in order to find a fixed point
if you've got a monotone function if you
want to compute
explicitly the least fixed point then in
in the worst case that requires omega n
queries
uh you know by deterministic algorithm
and even a randomized algorithm would
require
in expectation omega n uh queries and
likewise
for the greatest fixed point and um the
proofs of these facts are very simple
it's not this is
you know the easy stuff so the the first
one is a very simple
reduction from sat and for the second
one you can just think if
for this claim about the monotone
functions you know
let just f be the family of monotone
functions that
um where the top element is mapped to
itself
and for any value x either it's mapped
to itself
or to you know x plus one okay
the least fixed point of such a function
uh is obviously not equal to n
if and only if there exists some other
value that's mapped to itself
and in the but in the oracle model
finding such an x basically requires
trying every point
okay okay um
okay um so let's go back to the
the tarsky problem where we're not
specifically
tasked with computing at least fixed
point or greatest fixed point we're just
happy with
any uh fixed point um
now this is a total search problem as
i've already mentioned
and there are two very well studied uh
discrete total search complexity classes
that we want to relate this problem to
so
pls which stands for polynomial local
search and p-pad which stands for
the polynomial parity argument directed
um
so i i don't want to sort of belabor
this because these are very familiar
complexity classes but pls basically
consists of
discrete local search problems that can
be phrased
as follows you're given some instance as
a string of zeros and ones
and you're also given a start solution
which has
length polynomial in the instance length
and you want to compute a locally
optimal solution
where a locally optimal solution
is with respect to some polynomial time
computable objective function
and a polynomial time computable
neighborhood function
um there are many pls complete problems
but
just one sort of canonical pls complete
problem is you're given a boolean
circuit
with n input gates and m output gates
and you want to compute
a vector x
such that the integer value of the
output
if you interpret the output of that
circuit the m bit output as an integer
that integer value is greater than or
equal to the integer value of
any neighbor of that point x and by
neighbor i mean any point x
prime which is within hamming distance
one of that point
okay and the p-pad
which i hope many of you are familiar
with it's a there's many ways to define
the complexity class p-pad but
one standard you know well-known by now
pipette complete problem
and this is a result due to chenin dang
is computing a
mixed nash equilibrium for a given
two-player normal form
or by matrix game is a p-pad complete
sort of and i i'll come back to
you know sort of the fact that you know
p-pad is also
very much related to computing fixed
points but
of brower functions so brower fixed
points of
continuous functions from a compact
comeback set to itself
okay so um
so what we show is that this tarsky
problem
is both in pls and in in
ppad so let me just give brief
proof sketches for for these things i'm
not going to be able to
give the proofs in detail the the proof
that tarski is in pls is
kind of relatively easy ignoring for the
moment
the um the
potential for the input function to be
non-monotone
if we simply okay sort of as so this is
really a proof sketch it's not the full
proof but
if we assume that the input function is
monotone
then you can just consider the following
uh to be
the the solution sets so the so
that you among which that you're you're
trying to search for a
kind of local optimum so the solution
set consists
of those vectors where x is less than or
equal to f of x
okay and uh we defined the objective
function to just be the sum of the
coordinates
and the neighborhood function to just be
that for a given point its neighbor is
just
f of x and it's actually not hard to
show
that you know x-star is a local optimum
of this you know neighborhood function
and
with this objective function if and only
if it's a
fixed point of the original function
okay
and i'm glossing over you know what you
do in the case where
the the input function that given by
boolean circuit happens to not be
monotone
okay on the other hand the proof that
tarsky is in p-pad
is substantially more involved it um
it uses firstly a characterization of
p-pad
from my work with yanakakis
on on kind of fixed-p and so forth where
essentially you can boil down p-pad to
the problem of computing a fixed point
of a um a polynomially piece-wise
linear uh continuous
function mapping let's say the unit n
cubed to itself
okay and um
what we do is we use a special simple
simplicial subdivision of the d cube due
to
fruit and tal which um
it's so i i don't want to get into the
nitty-gritty but basically this
uh food intolerable subdivision of the
unit n cube has
the nice property that the vertices of
every little sub-simplex are actually
totally ordered
in the same sense of the ordering that
we've been discussing
okay and that enables us
um to do a kind of divide and conquer
algorithm
to to show that tarsky is in p with a
p-pad
oracle by which i mean that so
what we're effectively able to do is we
take a monotone function
and by um sort of linearly
interpolating the that monotone function
in a suitably sized d-dimensional cube
we define a brower function a continuous
function from that space
a compact convex space to itself and
then
we can do a query at sort of speak the
midpoint
of a given cube and
that query um can allow us
to uh in a sense
so we sorry instead rather than thinking
about it sorry
as computing a a you know querying the
midpoint
let me say it like this actually this is
the correct way to say it
um we find the fixed point of that
function that the fixed point of that
function
may not even have integer coordinates so
it's certainly not necessarily going to
correspond to
a fixed point of the original discrete
function
but what we can then do is
using the answer using the location of
that fixed point
we can in a sense have the size of our
search space
for a fixed point of the original disk
discrete function
and i know this is very sketchy but
basically um
through repeated queries to a p-pad
oracle we can
find the fixed point of the original
discrete monotone function
and then how do we then assert that the
problem is in p-pad well this is
there's a result by bus and johnson that
says actually that p-pad
is closed under uh p-time turing
reductions so
p with a p-pad oracle is actually the
same thing as p-pad
okay so um
and we're just using that fact
okay so any questions at this point i'm
sorry that this was very sketchy but
um so uh
kusha are there uh problems that
are known to be in this intersection
uh yeah in fact uh so there's in fact a
very recent result that says that the
the the intersection so okay i i'll come
back to
problems that are known to be in this
intersection in fact it's already
known that for example solving simple
stochastic games
and as well as approximating the value
of
uh shapley's stochastic games are
problems that are both in pls and p-pad
okay but in fact
i'm going to come to that because we're
going to show that those problems are
actually reducible to tarsky
but um so but
there are there's there's in fact a
complexity class that was
defined by das kalakis and papa dimitri
called
a continuous local search which a very
recent result
by i think fernley savani
and um uh
hollander and uh goldberg has shown that
actually cls is equal to uh
pls intersect p-pad so so there so there
are problems that are known uh
to be in the intersection of pls and
p-pad
of course you know any sort of
polynomial time
search problem would be but but you know
i if if you're talking about things we
do not
yet know to be in polynomial time then i
think stochastic games are a good
example but
i'm going to come back to that because
actually one of the
results in this paper is that this very
broad class of games called super
modular games
is you know gonna actually be
basically equivalent uh to the starsky
problem so so i'm gonna come back to
that okay
so let me just make a few brief comments
so this is just
for those who may not be very familiar
with pls and ppad so
note that no search problem in pls or in
ppad can be np hard unless
np is equal to co np and so
this is just a property of total search
complexity classes like these
uh also since starsky is in both of them
it cannot be complete for either one
unless
there's a containment between pls and
p-pad like in either direction
and neither of these inclusions are
known nor
i would say are widely believed i mean
maybe there are some people who think
that
there might be some containment but
there are oracle results and so forth
so anyway i think it's not widely
believed that either of these
containments
hold okay uh so
but however we can provide some
tentative evidence that tarsky is
somewhat hard and indeed this is
relating
to stochastic games so and in a sense
it also relates things to the broader
topics within this
you know the the program that this games
and equilibrium workshop is part of
because indeed content simple stochastic
games are essentially
reachability games right in a stochastic
environment right so um so
the the following problems are
polynomial time reducible to tarsky
uh given an instance of condensed simple
stochastic games
just compute the exact value of the game
this is
paloma time reducible to tarsky and
given an instance of
shapley's original stochastic games and
given some positive epsilon
in binary compute an approximate value
v primes which is you know which
approximates the value of the
instance of shapley's game within
epsilon
okay so note that it's a long-standing
open problem whether the value of
simple stochastic games can be computed
in polynomial time and
it's at least as hard as solving parity
games and mean payoff games is well
known
and approximating the value of shaft
these games is in turn
actually at least as hard as computing
the value of simple stochastic games
we do not know reductions in the other
directions so
um in particular for example for
shapley's stochastic games
the value itself can actually be
irrational so that's why
we in a sense we have to talk about some
form of approximation i mean
we cannot like you know write down in a
finite number of bits
the exact value because it might be
irrational
okay um i i want to just maybe just
rather than going into the details of
why
uh the these reductions hold let me give
a very very high level
uh explanation of why these reductions
hold
so for both condons simple stochastic
games and for shapley's
stochastic games we can define
monotone functions but continuous
monotone functions from
let's say the unit n cube to itself that
has
in a sense one variable or one
coordinate for each
let's say state of the simple stochastic
game
right and um such that
the um for example in the context
of condensed simple stochastic games the
the standard way to
define that monotone function so i and
i rather i'm not going to go into the
details of this but this is
you know the way you define such a
monotone function
it defines a system of equations if you
like
where you know the function on the right
maps the unit n cube to itself
and it's monotone and continuous um
and the n vector of values of the simple
stochastic game starting at each
vertex is given by the least fixed point
solution
in in that coordinate okay the least
fixed point solution of this
system so you might say well wait a
second least fixed points were hard to
compute
well but it turns out by but that
through discounting and this was already
in the in the original work by condon
there's discounting going on
through discounting for any you know
positive discount
uh the the resulting function by the way
if you discount the equations if in
effect by a discount the resulting
function is monotone
but the right hand side defines a mono
a contraction mapping as well not just a
monotone map but a contraction map
so by panax fixed point theorem there's
a unique
fixed point right so once there's a
unique fixed point
we're home free right but except that
this is a continuous function
right and we have to discretize it so
now
it's possible to choose a small enough
beta
such that the uh the
fixed point the unique fixed point of
the discounted function
is basically close to close enough
to the the original fixed point at least
fixed point
and finally we can discretize the
monotone function
and you know a fixed point of the
discretized function
yields a point that is epsilon close to
the unique fixed point
of the discounted function and from that
we can uniquely recover
uh the the fixed point of the original
function
it's this is all very sketchy but i hope
you get the general idea and
um now in the context of um shapley's
stochastic games
in a sense they are discounted to begin
with and they in a sense
are by you know just even shapley's
original equations
end up it ends up being the case they
have a unique
fixed point and the functions define a
monotone function so the same
sort of discretization apparatus works
okay so this is not you know
it's not a very difficult result okay
but okay let's move on now so um
it turns out that this tarsky problem is
actually polynomial time
equivalent to computing a pure nash
equilibrium
for a certain very broad class of games
that are widely studied in economics um
so these are super modular games and a
slightly more general class of games
called games with strategic
complementarities so super modular games
were first defined and studied by topkis
in the late 70s
and games with strategic
complementarities which are
as i said a slight generalization were
defined by milgram and roberts
and the these i you know these are
you know papers with you know uh you
know
thousands of citations there's you know
there's um you know many many
applications of the
of these in economics for for example
modeling oligopolies
sort of markets with search costs if
you've heard of things like the diamond
search model
bank runs arms races it there's you know
really a myriad of applications of of
these
and basically the there's
um so firstly one thing to say is that
these games always have a pure nash
equilibrium
and the proof of existence for pure nash
equilibrium uses the fact
and this is in a sense a crucial fact
that actually also
to some extent explains the wide
applicability of these games
right the the crucial fact about these
games is
that their best response correspondence
in particular the
if you think of the in female value of
their best response correspondence
as defining a function that function
is a monotone function and so you can
basically just
apply tarsky's fixed point theorem to
that monotone function
and it tells you that there must exist a
pure nash equilibrium
so um and and so what i was saying
before is that
in a sense um let me just kind of give
an example of the kinds of things that
people study with these super modular
games
if if you're in an environment where
let's say there's
several different you know you know the
you know gas stations in at some place
they're all gas companies if one of them
raises its price
the others are not incentivized to lower
their price
right so in a sense you know the the
best response
is kind of a monotone function
in that set so so that's kind of a one
example
and i'm being very sort of sketchy about
that but basically
um there's lots of settings where where
this kind of this applies
and so let me first state our results
before uh stating more formally the
definition of these kinds of games so
turns out that computing a pure nash
equilibrium for a given
k-player discrete super modular game and
you can also state analogous statements
for approximate equilibrium
in the context of uh you know not
non-discrete uh
super modular games but for discrete
super marginal games with
strategy spaces that you know are that
this euclidean grid lattice
um if you if you are given
the best response correspondence but
let's say by by
a kind of succinctly by by by a al
by a boolean circuit then
it's you know this is p time reducible
to the tarsky problem and in a sense
if you look at what i'm saying up here
it should not be too surprising that
that
is the case but it's not entirely
trivial to do that
interestingly though interestingly
though there's also a reduction in the
other direction so
tarsky is p-time reducible to computing
a pure nash equilibrium for a given just
two-player discrete super modular game
where the strategy space is you know
again the same euclidean grid
for each player okay
so um i don't know do
do we have time for me to actually
define what what we mean by super
modular games or should i just sort of
try to go on i i don't actually know how
much time i have
so maybe i should have you have uh
you you have till one o'clock yeah well
i guess 50 yeah 15 more minutes yeah
okay good so
so so let me then try to quick briefly
go through what
we mean by a super modular game so first
just the basic definitions about what
you mean by a super modular function so
a function from a lattice to the reals
is super modular if for any two elements
of the lattice
fx plus fy is less than or equal to f
of the meat of x and y plus f
of the join of x and y and
you know and a function from
the cartesian product of two lattices to
the reals
is called i is a function of increasing
differences
in its two arguments if for
x prime greater than or equal to x and y
prime greater than or equal to y
uh the x these being in l1 and these
being in l2
uh the the difference between f x prime
y prime and
f x prime y is greater than or equal to
the difference between f
x y prime uh and f x
y okay so the i mean i hope it's clear
why
this is called increasing differences
right so when we
when we increase from x to x prime
on the left-hand side here the
difference
increases okay all right okay so
in a super modular game with k players
um each player
has a complete lattice of strategies and
if we denote by the you know
the set of all combinations of
strategies to be
s right this is the cartesian product of
of their strategy spaces
it denotes in a sense the product
lattice right
every player's utility function which
maps
you know you know combinations of
strategies to the reels
must satisfy the following conditions
and ignore this first condition from the
point of view if the lattice was finite
these co
the first condition about
semi-continuity and whatnot
is just trivial okay the second
condition says that the function must be
super modular
in you know the the you know the the
strategy of that player itself
the strategy si for a fixed you know
values of the strategies of the other
players and
it the the function must have increasing
differences
in s i and s i minus i so if these are
the two
uh arguments of the you know
the function then it should have
increasing differences in those two
arguments
and and this then guarantees the
properties that i was saying before that
the function
is uh has you know kind of a
a monotone best response correspondence
and a monotone in female best response
function
okay okay
so let me now mention
um in terms of
lower bounds for the starsky problem so
of course
we don't have lower bounds in the you
know standard model of computation
and now even in the black box oracle
model of computation where we just
imagine that the only way we're able to
access
the the function is just to evaluate it
at given points right
um so for that setting
what we show is that
both any deterministic black box oracle
algorithm for computing a tarsky fixed
point already in the two-dimensional
setting
right requires uh
omega of log squared n queries so
remember the upper bound was
uh order log squared n so
basically this matches the upper bound
but only in two dimensions
okay and the same holds for randomized
algorithms so any randomized black box
algorithm for computing a tarsky fixed
point
of a two-dimensional amount of monotone
function requires
omega log squared and queries in
expectation or with high probability
um so um
and let me just briefly indicate so the
lower bound proof uses a
family of functions which we call
herringbones
whose vector field looks a bit like a if
that the reason to call them
herringbones is
their vector field looks a bit like a
fish fish bone and they have a unique
fixed point so let me show what an
example of these functions looks like so
here's an example of a herringbone so
this
this this herringbone has has a spine
so if you start at the bottom there's a
spine
and if you start at the top there is a
spine and
you're ascending along that spine up
until a fixed point and you're
descending along that spine up until the
fixed point
and now this spine may meander around
not necessarily you know going in some
kind of diagonal line or anything like
that
all right but off off of that spine
all other points just kind of move
diagonally
towards the the point on the spine
which is in a sense on the same level
set as
um as the given point so by
by level set i mean where the sum of the
coordinates is the same right
so so this is just one
simple example of of such a herringbone
function
from you know you know with you know
sides of length five but you can imagine
the general
definition of these kinds of herringbone
functions and it turns out that already
for these herringbone functions that
have
a unique fixed point and uh
that you know and you know
seemingly extremely simple nevertheless
log squared
and many queries is required in order to
find a fixed point for
these functions and um i mean
i i sort of we give in effect sort of
two different
uh you know proofs of this when for the
disc for the deterministic case it's
kind of a adversarial argument and and
uh you know there you sort of set up
an appropriate potential function and an
adversarial argument to say that kind of
you know the adversary can answer in
such a way to keep
lots and lots of possibilities still
going but
you know i don't want to get into the
details of that and
in the um for the randomized setting
you know as is con standard in these
things we use
a kind of yao's mini max principle that
says
uh it suffices to sort of
put a difficult distribution a
probability distribution
on these instances on these herringbones
such that um that even the best
deterministic algorithm against
that probabilistic probability
distribution on these herringbones
would require log squared and many uh
queries and and that's indeed what we
showed
it log squared and many queries in
expectation or with high probability
okay so okay so let me just conclude now
and we can then you know
go into questions so we have shown that
tarsky is both in pls and p-pad
and we have shown that tarsky is at
least as hard as solving both
the simple stochastic games and shapley
stochastic games
and just as hard as finding a pure nash
equilibrium for super modular games
um we've shown that in the oracle model
for two-dimensional monotone functions
uh there's a lower bound of or or order
log squared n uh you know for
let's say the the number of queries
required also
in the randomized setting in expectation
uh which matches the upper bound um
so an obvious question is uh can we do
much better than
log to the dn for small values of n
um so we know as i said for
large values of n that the dn upper
bound
is actually already better than log to
the
dn right so so asymptotically you know
when you're in the regime where d is uh
you know
little omega of log n over log log n
the d times n upper bound is actually
better okay but maybe for
small fixed values let's say three
maybe one can't do better than log to
the dn and in fact
in our paper we had said oh you know
it's tempting to conjecture that for
small fixed values of d
maybe the log n to the d is is optimal
but in fact we were wrong so you know
very very recent result by
fernley and savani shows that for d
greater than or equal to three they give
a
log to the d minus one n uh upper bound
so in other words they shave
one a you know they shave a you know
additive factor one off the exponent
here uh for finding a fixed point
uh right so so that's the result by
fernley and savani and and it's actually
you know not a very difficult
uh result so this is going to i think
appear in stacks
later this year it's a very nice
argument and it just in a sense
the their results just establishes a
certain
uh nice the result for
in the three-dimensional case and then
they uh you know extend it to higher
dimensions
um but okay but that leaves
still many many questions open so in
some sense the title of my talk
was um a um
not not a great title in the sense that
i say i
the complexity of this tarsky fixed
point problem but
actually i have no idea what the
complexity of this tarsky fixed point
problem is because we yes we know it's
in pls and it's in p-pad
and we know that it's at least as hard
as you know stochastic games
and and you know that it has the same
you know sort of it's
you know polynomial time equivalent to a
certain succinct
representation of you know the problem
of finding a
nash pure nash equilibrium for a super
modular game
but um but you know for all we know
this problem you know could have much
more efficient algorithms of course
these would be a breakthrough because in
particular they would help us
you know solve sarcastic games but
you know i i think i'm i'm at this point
actually quite optimistic
that there will be quite a lot better
upper bounds and even
potentially in the just the black black
box oracle setting
there might be better upper bounds for
these problems
and um okay so i'll leave it there and
open the floor for questions
yeah thanks krishna uh yeah are there
any questions
i think people can just unmute
themselves and
ask questions
i have a question uh hi kusha hi
yeah so this is albert speaking hi
albert hi hi
so we have a couple of questions the
first is about this
pure nash equilibrium of super modeler
games you say it's
equivalent to your problem i i should be
a little bit careful when i say
equivalent it's
assuming that you have a um
way of succinctly representing the best
responses
best response function if you like or
best response correspondence
of the the game because in general
if you allow arbitrary utility functions
let's say given to you succinctly then
even just
optimizing the utility function you know
kind of optimizing
you know for fixed values of other
people's strategies optimizing your own
strategy
you know to come up with a best response
but you know
maybe a hard problem and so so in a
sense
um we need some device to make the
kind of the representation of the super
modular game
amenable to potentially efficiently
uh you know computing a a a fixed point
or a equilibrium i don't know if that
made sense or not
yeah well more or less so assuming you
have this condition that you need
when you do the reduction you are
presumably are producing a function that
is monitoring
uh so
is it right to be monotone or or
that's right so so if if now now
now here's the the catch there so there
your your question might be well how do
you avoid the promise
well there is an implicit promise which
is that
if the original best response function
that you were given
was coming from an actual uh super
modular game
then that best response function would
be monotone
okay right so do you see what i mean
yeah yeah i think so okay so
okay so it's not like you are ensuring
the the promise it's there is a promise
in the problem of origin itself
in some sense yes yeah yeah
i mean you can consider these two
problems both of them
in the promised version and the promised
versions are reducible to each other
in the same way right that's
okay
hi thank you for the really nice talk so
your result essentially indicates that
uh finding a fixed point in this lattice
should be reducible to find a brower
fixed point
of a a continuous function
on uh you know on a convex uh
compact set right because it's prepared
essentially
that's right but the proof is a bit
indirect because as i said the first
thing so
you know i yes so your proof goes
through these intermediate points
but is there a way now in retrospect to
say that uh
here's how you embed the lattice and a
monotone function on a lattice to a
continuous function and convex
it no so you see we actually
do an embedding of the monotone discrete
function
in a continuous function but the problem
is that that
resulting continuous function may have
fixed points
that are not themselves at integer
lattice points
in a sense those fixed points
may have let's say kind of coordinates
like
one half or i don't know one over three
or so whatever right
and then we have to decide okay what
does that fixed point then tell me
suppose
because remember in the context of the
the brower
fixed point problem all we're
told is we're going to get some fixed
point back we're not told which fixed
point right
so we get some fixed point back and the
question is can we learn anything from
it and the crucial thing that the proof
shows is that yes we can learn something
from any fixed point that you give me
back
and in fact we can use any fixed point
you give me back
to narrow the search space for finding
an actual discrete fixed point
in but so that it's at least splits the
search space by a half
in in some sense okay that's
kind of what's going on in that uh in
that result
um
um yeah um
yeah i mean maybe a kind of a comment i
should say is that kind of
i i i think that this um
this alternative view embedding problems
like
solving stochastic games in this tarsky
problem
actually also presents a kind of
different algorithmic paradigm
for trying to solve things like simple
stochastic games and
in some sense you know currently we know
for example quasi-polynomial time
algorithms for solving parity games
but we do not know quasi-polynomial time
algorithms for solving
let's say mean payoff games or simple
stochastic games and so forth
and you know being super super
optimistic one could hope
that you know with you know many
improvements one could somehow come up
with a quasi-polynomial time algorithm
for
the tarsky problem but i think we're way
far away from that at this point
it's just sort of i'm just laying it out
there as something that
we certainly have not ruled out um
if we have a minute for another question
if i may
so the simple stochastic games you can
also formulate as a decision problem
like uh
i mean
it's not so much remember it has a value
so you can
formulate it as a decision problem to
say is the value let's say less than or
equal to a half
sure okay so the question is whether
your problem the task
problem can be formulated as a decision
problem in a natural way that becomes
equivalent
um okay uh
i so so okay
so um
[Music]
you see if you if you make it for
example
as a question like does there exist a
fixed point which has like which is
below this value in some coordinate
that's a harder problem because you can
use that for example to compute the
least fixed point
right but i guess there's you know sort
of
just the same as you do with for example
um sort of turning questions for example
for broward fixed
computation problems you can also
convert those to questions that are
you know in a sense decision questions
but benign in the sense that they don't
give away
uh the ant and so the one way you could
do it is you could say
um let's see so
um
i have to think about it i think there's
ways to do it but it's not
you know sort of it's not terribly
um um
it's not terribly revealing beyond you
know sort of so solving the tarsky
problem itself
is going to be kind of right so let's
see but the reason i'm asking is because
um so once you have a decision problem
you can
ask questions whether it's in np
intersection point p
and whether you have certificates for
that problem or
right yeah but remember these are
kind of total search problems so kind of
um yeah
um
it's something to think about i guess
it's something i would like to have
for example for simple stochastic games
i have a proof system to show
that uh one player can win or not right
so i want to i want to look at it this
way as an np problem
rather than as a total search problem
that that's my motivation for the
question okay
okay um
we can take it offline but i'm sure we
can devise a
kind of simple enough way of viewing it
it'll be
it won't be sort of simple decision like
is you know the
you know whatever some coordinate of it
less than or equal to something that
that we cannot do because it gives away
things like the least fixed point but
you know they're
yeah any other
questions
well i guess not uh yeah so yeah thank
you kusha very much
for a great talk
and we will anyone if they have
questions i guess
they can contact kusha later
and i think this slides will be posted
on
the workshop web page uh soon
yeah i think ashley will get in touch
with you about that yeah
okay do you know who the
speaker for the next week is
for the workshop they
i think next week we have vince conitzer
uh
speaking at this workshop and
i will just look up the the title
okay yeah so uh next week we have vince
connitzer
speaking about designing agents
preferences beliefs and identities
okay so that will be a very
okay so oh yes so thanks uh thanks
everyone for attending
and thanks gusha again okay
thank you thanks very much bye bye